I'm Josh Rauh I'm a professor of finance
at the Stanford Graduate School of
Business and a senior fellow at the
Hoover Institution at Stanford
University and also at the Stanford
Institute for Economic Policy Research
and I'm really excited to be talking to
you today about this open online course
that we're doing about the finance of
retirement and pensions if you're in the
workforce now and you're thinking gee I
really need a long-term financial plan
for retirement then the tools in this
course are gonna be really useful for
you it doesn't matter whether you're age
25 and just starting work or even even
before that I want to get a head start
and understanding these things or if
your age 65 and are thinking about
retiring in a couple years
these tools are fundamental and are
gonna be very useful for your financial
planning if you're a taxpayer and you're
thinking about Social Security or public
sector pension systems how are these
programs going to affect me what am I
gonna get out of these programs what am
I gonna pay into these programs then the
tools that we're gonna have in this
course are really gonna help you be more
informed about these programs and also
understand the discussions that are
going on in the public policy sphere in
a more sensible way I want to empower
you to make better decisions about your
own portfolios about your own long-term
savings and investment strategies as you
prepare for retirement because today
people have to take more responsibility
for their own financial preparation for
retirement than they ever have before
let me talk about some of the elements
of this course we've got video lectures
but these are gonna be much different
from the video lectures you might have
seen in other MOOCs we've got a lot of
great graphics coming in we've got
moving maps of what we're doing at any
given time in the MOOC and any given
moment in the MOOC and you can download
these maps they'll really allow you to
chart out so that the whole course got
webinars where we've got both experts
forums and opportunities for you as the
students to present your work we're also
going to have these weekly video updates
where I will talk with you over video
about
the class the content some of the
student projects some of the things that
are going on in current affairs as well
surrounding pinches in retirement I
think that will help keep things very
current with class the course will
culminate in an interactive symposium
about the challenges facing us pension
systems we're going to hold this in
January 2014 at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business and the event will
feature representatives of the MOOC
teams with the five most promising ideas
for pension reform one represented from
each team is gonna present the proposals
to a distinguished panel of faculty and
experts in finance and public policy the
expenses for the presenters are going to
be covered by the Stanford Graduate
School of Business and the Hoover
Institution at Stanford University I'm
really looking forward to seeing you in
class